hello everyone and welcome to film
independent presents our year-round
screening and q a series now
virtual i'm brian sheehan with film
dependent thank you so much for joining
us today to discuss all things the
sparks brothers
first off i'd like to thank some of our
art and supporters our lead sponsor the
hollywood farm press association
and our screening partner vision media
um
we have a very special guest moderator
today
uh in keri brownstein and uh during the
discussion if you have any questions for
our participants
please use the q a button towards the
bottom of your screen
and without further ado i will let
carrie take it away from here
all right well hello and thank you for
having me um
i have been tasked with an introduction
which i feel like
uh i don't know if either the sparks or
edgar wright need an introduction but um
i will just say that i'm honored to be
here that i
am absolutely floored by this film the
sparks brothers i think it's brilliant
and delightful and just ineffable in the
way that
all great art and music should be um
it's a 360 degree
view of this band but also somehow
leaves portals
to the unknown and keeps the mystery
alive which i think is
so important for um for art and the
continued
conversation we have with it throughout
all the years that i've been making
music if you get on a tour bus
with a bunch of musicians
eventually the conversation will go to
sparks
i remember just seeing them all the time
like who are those guys
they are a band you can look up on
wikipedia and know
nothing we are sparks
dude please welcome
frequently asked questions about sparks
how many m's are there 25
albums are you brothers we are brothers
how did you first meet
we are brothers music at its best you
hear and you go oh my god
what is that it's insane but it's
fantastic
each time you'd go to the rehearsal
there'd be something new there
like that's good it wasn't like anything
else
all pop music is rearranged sparks
that's the truth
there are throwaway rifts that other
bands have built whole
careers out of one of my favorite
moments is john lennon ringing up ringo
starr
you won't believe what's on the
television
[Music]
it was the sound of the future
sparks is way more prolific than all of
the artists we consider to be the
greatest in the world
they sort of set a template that a
beetle would pretend to be wrong
that's amazing they were taking
all their creative juices and putting it
into something that they loved they were
a bit much for most people
the culture just wasn't there yet is
there anybody out there at all right now
they've reinvented themselves several
times the thing that
marked them was their unwillingness to
give up
that sounds like the scene from our
biopic
our time has come here
[Applause]
they may have given birth to other bands
who don't even know
that the lineage goes back to them
[Music]
still are waiting to get paid back for
that
why have you resisted doing a
documentary until now we didn't want to
do the standard documentary full of
talking ants
it would become too dry
so i'm joined of course by the male
brothers russell
and ron and the director of the sparks
brothers edgar wright
and we're going to have a conversation
today about
this fabulous movie the sparks music
i will say one i would you want to start
with there was this moment
just my own sparks anecdote of
discovering your band
which was i was in my 20s and um
it's a similar story i think beck in the
movie says something like on every tour
bus
on every tour that you get to this point
in the tour where someone will bring up
sparks
another musician and this happened to me
and i will name drop thurston moore from
sonic youth
having a barbecue in portland oregon and
i mentioned the band
queen how much i love them and he turned
to me he was having another conversation
and he said queen they're just a rip-off
of sparks go
thurston
it just it stung me because here's this
this musician who i
idolized and he's telling me that i am
missing out
on this band that has influenced another
band
and i just thought what is this lack of
knowledge in my
musical history and i have spent the
last
15 years listening and loving
your music and i know many people have
so
anyway thanks for being here thank you
thank you
do you still listen to queen that's the
only question no i had to throw i had to
burn all their records okay thank you
thank you
thank you okay
um so i'm now qualified to do this um
all right well starting uh out with
some basic questions i guess knowing
that ron and and russ were
reticent to make a documentary that
they're you know that
has that way of sort of ossifying uh
an entity or kind of feeling like oh
here's the um
you know this is this is a memorial um
how did you convince
them that this should happen what were
those early conversations like
well i guess actually when i asked them
i wasn't aware
that they had the rest in the rest
oh my god they hadn't been reluctant in
the past um
to do a documentary in it and i didn't
know that they turned down other offers
and i guess in a way because
at the time when i kind of pitched it to
them which was actually
at the end of a sparks gig and i'll just
back up a little the context of it was
that i
and maybe carrie you might have even
heard me say it myself
i felt like i'd been just saying out
loud without necessarily thinking it was
me
saying that somebody should do a sparks
documentary
and just like anybody that would listen
especially fellow sparks fans would be
saying
somebody should do a documentary about
sparks they're like the most
influential greatest artist to not have
a documentary
and a sparks gig i was with phil lord
the director
and i i was giving this spiel and he
said
you should make the movie and then so i
said yeah i will and then during the
concert we
i watched sparks of the el rey i was
like thinking about it
and then after the concert i i pitched
it to ronald russell
and well they can answer in terms of why
they said yes but i think
the biggest part of it was that i was
going to cover them as an
ongoing concern because a lot of
music documentaries saying and hey you
remember the 70s
and then 15 minutes spent on the rest of
it
so i didn't want to do that because i
was in the sort of belief
that the sparks output of the last 20
years was as good as anything they did
in the 70s
and and in that sense there was no
golden period for sparks it was kind of
still
going so that was sort of my pitch is
that it was going to be as much about
what's happening now
as like hey remember the 70s
and yet yeah i mean and for all of those
reasons that edgar
said we uh and for what you said is well
care about
not wanting something to be ossified or
um
you know an obituary to to a group
um and here's your gold watch um
you know edgar had you know we we
discussed from the beginning but he
he had really convinced us that you know
it was gonna be um
you know sort of a thesis of um you know
what sparks is doing
now all the things that have led up to
to the to the present you know that that
there
wasn't that golden error like edward
just mentioned and
you know and we were such fans of
edgar's film so
that i think is the uh the the number
one uh
inducement was that we we loved all of
edgar's work and we thought there was a
real
connection but between what edgar does
with his films
and what sparks does with our music
there's some kind of
crossover there there's edgar's kinetic
style
and his you know use of uh things like
animations within his
films and and and really importantly the
use of music
in in most of his films that's such a
key element so we thought with all those
kind of factors playing into it that
that
it had to you know it had to work if
there was going to be anybody to
that could make could tell our story in
a way that we
felt was um you know a visual
kind of equivalent to what we do
musically that edgar was the guy
we our one fear was just that this would
be the one film that
didn't have kind of edgar rightness in
it that
that it would be just because it was a
documentary and
and he hasn't done a documentary before
that that all the things that we loved
about edgar's films
wouldn't be present in in this film but
we were
you know i wouldn't i wouldn't say
surprise but
but we were so pleased when we fin saw
the final cut because
it really feels like an an edgar wright
film
which is you know just ideal for us
yeah i would even say it feels like from
from the first moment of the film
i was just like oh this is such an edgar
movie but i think it's also an edgar
wright and sparks movie i mean
you know you guys have used a cinematic
language your entire career and it seems
like such a
um beautiful and you know explosive
fusion of the two were there any
cinematic
precedents for this for you know were
there films either narrative or
documentary that
you discussed as a group in terms of we
like this or we definitely don't want to
do this
we didn't really talk too much about i
didn't really talk too much about the
style
with you guys i guess there was just
things i had ideas for things and i just
pitched it to ronald russell like i said
i want to do all the interviews in the
same way because i want to have an
equivalence between
every interviewee um so that there's no
difference between
duran duran and you know uh julia marcus
who was a stage invader age 14. um
but also like to shoot them in the style
of the richard avedon cover of bigby
i thought it would be nice to do and
make all of the interviews look sort of
timeless so that then
there's so much archive and so much
color in the archive
um and then i think it was things like
just i guess i pitched some of the ideas
of
sometimes they're quite late in the day
like things like the faq
section you know um hey why don't we do
like a frequently asked questions
at the start and i think i wrote the
questions and you you came in the next
day
with all your witty pithy answers
rehearsed and then like later there were
things like the thing that's in the end
credits i think because i shot the
interviews with ronald russell
maybe about like nine hours of
interviews over four days but the four
days were
spread out over the whole process and
very close to the end isil had this idea
about
what if we just put out a bunch of
bullshit facts in the end
credits to keep people guessing so again
ronan russell wrote all of those but it
was so this thing of just kind of like
floating ideas like the visual puns and
the kind of the questions but
so there was that and then i guess like
style-wise like
i don't know i mean i i i do watch a lot
of music documentaries
i guess one documentary maker that i
really enjoy what he's done
is julian temple like i love the filth
and the fury documentary because i
thought
the way he used archive to give context
was really
great and in this movie because we're
covering
unlike a lot of music documentaries are
covering it a bigger span of time
than most music documentaries it was it
was a gift in a way because not only is
there
tons of amazing sparks archive but you
end up going
on a journey through pop culture at the
same time so
you know it was it was a sort of a
a big sort of herculean task to wrangle
it all but
but it was never you were never short of
like ideas or things to go to
which was you know a gift you know
and was there anything that you in early
cuts i
assume that ron and russell saw or edgar
as you would
conduct other interviews or discover
things in in the
research that adjusted
your questions like do you have to do go
back and interview anyone or
interview the band because you thought
uh we haven't this thing has been on
earth this discovery has
happened and now we need to dive in or
did that happen at all
i think at the very end the last thing i
did with you guys interviewing you
in the studio was um
uh i did like a solo interview i mean
i guess that's one of the things i
didn't really think that it would be so
kind of unique but that's but then
here's
i i shot ronald russell in two shots for
the entire film because i've
rarely met ron russell separately so
in my head it's like it's not like
you're kind of a two-headed monster
but in my head it's like you come as a
pair and i'll interview you as a pair
but then at the end it was like i want
to do 90 minutes with both of you
separately and and in that part which we
did last
um you know i i had interviewed some of
the other people so i had
questions and things that they had said
that i could ask ron and russell about
i guess the the one thing that did
change things and like thank
god it happened on all levels is that
when we went into production on the
documentary
um the leos carrick's film and net which
ronald russell wrote
wasn't definitely happening it was sort
of maybe happening but it had not been
green lit
and then i think by the time we
finishing the documentary and then i was
making
my next film last night in soho during
that time
a net was green lit and so as soon as i
heard that that was happening i said to
my producer
said we have to go to the set of a net
and in fact that was the last bit
filming
i did with ron russell and indeed the
last time i saw them in person as well
because of if you heard about the
pandemic but like we've all been in
different countries
so i guess that's the thing is if if
like i mean listen i've
i can say this on camera i've seen a net
and it's stunning and i cannot wait for
you all to see it
but i also just on a purely selfish
level i'm really glad that it got
greenlit so that my
b plot in the movie would have a happy
ending
ron and russell was there anything
as you started to embrace the idea of
doing this documentary
that you felt like was off limits that
you
were unwilling or hesitant to explore
at all well in a certain way it was more
like
we were worried that there wasn't enough
to explore
that that what we do as a band
and just the visuals live and and
on album out artwork and and those sorts
of things was more interesting
than you know some deep dark secret
which we're
not really aware of and so so you know
but
ed you're assured us at the beginning
don't don't worry it'll be
you know when when you see the
documentary um
you'll be interesting and so so that
you know that that was an important
thing for us because you know it was one
reason why we never wanted a documentary
we always felt that
what we were doing as a band was saying
everything
that needed to be said about our
sensibilities or even us
personally but but um you know that
we we can see that there was a way to
frame a documentary work
where things could be kind of rounded
off a little more and still
and still work because we don't we don't
have the we don't have those kind of
little extra
uh moments like you know drug overdoses
and and kind of introspective rebounds
and
and uh divorces and all these sorts of
things they kind of
make other music documentaries maybe a
little more
spicy but uh we we shouldn't have we
shouldn't have worried that
if it got taken care of by just
brilliant filmmaking
yeah definitely and also i think that
was
i mean that just happens to be your
story that it lacks
you know the the kind of i guess cliches
but also
some of the tropes of you know the the
life of
uh rock band but i felt that that way
i could just immerse into the art you
know that there was
there was something so pure about it
um in terms of go ahead
no i was just gonna add what you what
you just said is
i i felt that way in terms of with
ronald russell's concern i think maybe
russell you said
in jest at some point that there was no
kind of not enough soap opera
you know but i was on the flip side of
saying every other music documentary has
that and every other music documentary
is the rise and fall and rise and
to me and i'm sure you feel the same way
carrie is it's a it's a testament to
dedication to the craft
and that alone in this in this
especially in this current climate with
musicians having it harder than ever
before
just to sort of see ron russell figure
out a way to make it work for them
i think it's just so inspiring because
like
i i i hope i'm doing work as good as
them you know like
as they are now it's it's incredible
it's just like i just feel it's some
that it it becomes in that sense of like
what might seem like a monastic approach
to being a band
to me it's just like the persistence of
vision and i feel like
sometimes with bands like sometimes
there's like true tragedy
and sometimes there's things where you
feel that people have squandered what
they have and you
so don't really have any sympathy for
like people who kind of just like
blow all their money up the wall and
just kind of like just
you know self-destructive in a way that
like
you can't sort of sympathize with and so
see
on the flip side people like work really
really hard
for 50 years is sort of extraordinary
for sure so ron you said that you know
one thing was was wanting that you've
always felt like the work
speaks for itself which i think is true
but yet watching the film
back and knowing that the messages
were always merged with the art itself
did either of you have any moments of
reassessment or
seeing something in your past albums or
visuals that
you hadn't thought about before was
there any sense of
contemplation or enlightenment there or
i don't know just yeah i think just the
idea that
other people have scrutinized this so so
deeply along the way with you know
we maybe i shouldn't be surprised in
some sense but
but you know we we kind of we
we that kind of depth and breadth of of
scrutiny in a in a good sense uh you
know an
analysis of of what we've done you know
we never
we never realized that and and kind of
uh
maybe it's just partially ego stroking
or something like that but
but to to see that and kind of all
contained within the documentary
you know we i mean we were semi aware of
where we stand
in in in the overall picture but
but you know it it was really inspiring
to us
to to have that level of of depth of
insight into what we were doing
you sometimes much more than we would
have about what we're doing and
and from people that that are from all
different
areas of the arts right writers and
comedians and actors and then
and also musicians from all different
fields so that
that was a surprise at least to me
it was really amazing to see just even
you know
writers like neil gaiman but discussing
um theories about the album covers of
ours like
the propaganda cover exactly what was
going on
what what was behind the uh the
you know the kidnapping scene that's
that's going on there and stuff and so
to know that even album covers were
getting this kind of
attention and scrutiny by by writers
that we respect was you know it was
really amazing and just a
credit to edgar to kind of for having
reached out to this uh
broad group of uh creative types
and that you know them agreeing to
participate in this was
was something for us that was just so
heartwarming
yeah i loved all the all the commentary
and i do love edgar that you
posited them in the same kind of
monolithic space i think just
visually it really worked but it also
just it helped with the kind of
i don't know i guess also the how i
think of the sparks is monolithic it's
just like it's a it's a world that
that is very intentional and fully
formed so i love
that that merging there um in terms of
collaboration wrestle and ron i mean
what do you think
is like what makes a good collaborator
why why are you guys good collaborators
well i mean i think in in our case being
brothers
actually is the reason it's working and
has worked for
so long contrary to all the other
brothers acts that
can't stand each other and uh you know
are really at odds with each other and
for us it's kind of been
just the opposite um that
um we kind of have this talkative in
various ways
you know within the confines of pop
music and and so i think if we hadn't
been brothers
we the collaborative side of things
would have probably fallen apart you
know
ages and ages ago and so i think that
that's been
the one the constant throughout this and
we kind of don't have to ever
talk about uh philosophies of music
or our music or where we're headed we
just
kind of have a sense for it and we can
also in our case kind of not worry about
doing something foolish in the studio we
have a studio in my place now
and if some if we do something and try
something
and it's really ridiculous uh and it
doesn't
pan out well no one will ever hear it
except the two of us and we don't care
what
the other things you know it's we won't
in that kind of way and so
so uh you know it's a it's uh
probably the best you know situation in
our case obviously it's
it's unique because uh there's more of
the other brothers acts where it's not
working out that way for whatever
reasons
for sure edgar do you feel like
what is the difference in terms of the
collaborative process
in working on narrative versus
documentary because obviously with
documentary
you're collaborating with with subjects
you know in
in this case subjects who are very much
alive and who you respect and
you know so i'm just curious how that
collaborative process filmmaking
obviously is
from the al already but how this
differed
well i guess you know making a narrative
film that you have something in your
head and you're trying to sort of bring
that to
your screen so usually like you're
against yourself all the time
and usually whenever you're like
disappointed with something it's like
because it doesn't
look or sound like it did in your head
it's like how can i make it more like
the thing that i dreamt about
in this case like tackling their life
and their work
it's it's more about finding ways to
sort of
present it in a way and and also and
respect it but also
but also tell the story so i mean i
think i think the thing with
and having known them a couple of years
before i even asked them about the
documentary
um i knew that we had a shared sense of
humor and i guess in like
um you know in that way that i mean but
then in a strange way part of my sense
of humor is growing up listening to
sparks
i feel like it was kind of destined to
be at a certain point
[Laughter]
um but it is it is that thing where you
sort of
i mean it is the nicest thing about like
um
[Music]
you know me you know they say don't meet
your heroes but this is a sort of
glorious exception to that
and i think weedly like when we like met
you know
aside from me asking all my geeky fan
questions like we would sort of just
talk about
films and like comedy and art and you
know like
and so i knew that we had a shared
sensibility
and so and so that kind of gave
me license to sort of know what ronald
russell's sense of humor was
which is obviously very evident in the
in the work and the stagecraft and the
videos and the album covers
um to sort of how to present the
documentary and i think the
key thing is similar to what ron says in
the film about jean-luc goddard
is you know talking about the french new
wave that jolly goddard would make
movies and
comment on them at the same time and i
think what sparks do brilliantly is like
really serious about and passionate
about their songcraft and the emotions
in the song are very real
but it doesn't stop them from having fun
with the form
and so i sort of decided to approach the
documentary in the same way is that
i'm really serious and passionate about
sparks but that's not going to stop me
from like having a little fun with them
and
sort of taking the piss out of the music
documentary at the same time
even though i love music documentaries
so it was it was sort of a gift in a way
to sort of
be able to have that tone and it because
you know they're not a po face band and
that's and that's a gift you know it's
said in the documentary quite a few
times
by people saying that like having humor
and music together is something that's a
challenge for some audiences
um but to me it's like it's why they're
memorable
and also in terms of making the
documentary it was such a kind of like
a pleasure to be able to have a little
fun with it along the way
the show we we're on the same wavelength
too and just the brief anecdote and it
won't get bogged down but
edgar uh he in the documentary showed
this
little snippet of a film that i did at
ucla film school
when i was starting it's it's not a good
film but it
um you know it was sort of a little
homage or or a
ripoff of uh trying to be a french new
wave
film and so found out
on after talking about that edgar had
done
the exact film not the exact sub
but he had done his little homage um
to a to french new wave film kind of
taking the piss in a
certain way too and and his was
basically
identical shorts shot like 30 years
apart
is really strange this needs to be bonus
content i mean we've seen
you know we've seen russell's but we
need we need you to release yours ender
we we literally make the same joke in
both things
like yours is like oh manky and you call
him um
jean paul manky and then my friend whose
name was phil it was like
jean john phil like but also like his
russell's one was called trey sirius and
my one
was called brainless a buddha lemon
souffle and it's basically the same
short like made at college it's kind of
crazy
so you guys are having this
having this moment now but in a 50-year
career there are
so many moments as you when you're
looking back which i suppose this film
forces you to do
do you do you have a sense that you were
enjoying those moments
even the the ebbs and flows like as
you're watching
footage of yourself do you enjoy things
now
are you able to sort of exist with
a sense of of gratitude now in a way
that you weren't then or have you always
felt
present in in the many vicissitudes of
this band
well i probably enjoyed the flows a
little more than the abs i guess
but um you know when when
when you're involved in the in the thing
we're kind of always
i mean i i suppose there is a moment
where you try to relish something that's
positive but
we're always kind of trying to move on
to the next thing because i'm always
nervous
that well what hap is is there anything
else that i'll be able to come up with
you know i mean i
i know we have 25 albums but that fear
is there
all the time and so
so i guess i'm not able to kind of
cherish those moments as much as i
should because i'm i'm worried about
what if i don't come up with another
song uh i don't want to live on memories
you know so
so it it there is that but i mean
the the times where something has
happened i mean
there have been surprises like when we
had the first two albums out in the
states that did
nothing in the early 70s and then island
records brought us to
the uk and we to reform a ban and then
we had this
immediate kind of success
um you know you you kind of think wow
this is
unbelievable you're kind of seeing
yourself in this situation because we
always
dreamed to be a big british fan and here
we were
but it kind of didn't last for very long
because then
you know it's like okay you need to come
up with another album and then
uh you're on to kind of just the actual
kind of work of doing it so i i suppose
you know this the documentary was a
moment to kind of
look at those things and at least for
two hours and 20 minutes of my life and
just
and just say you know um
that that was that was pretty special
both the good things and the bad things
and also just the just the kind of early
feedback we've gotten from people who
have seen the
film at festivals and stuff it's been
really inspiring
to us too to hear from a lot of really
young people
saying that the story
um has been inspirational for them as
creative types and it show it gives them
kind of some validation to just
also follow their own um you know their
own
path and to to retain their own
integrity in whatever they're doing
creatively and as as a kind of a
byproduct of the film which we
we didn't think that there would be that
kind of inspirational side
to you know to other people to other
young people and creative types to kind
of just
stick with your own vision and and have
blinders on and
and don't worry what anybody else says
about your creative pursuits
that's been also inspiring to us as a
result of the documentary so that
it's been really really cool
well i can definitely second that as a
takeaway from the film and i'll
all and we're going to move over to
audience q a for the last 15 but i guess
my last
question is to edgar and it kind of
plays off what both ron and russell were
just talking about
what have sparks and this film
taught you as an artist about
perseverance and
longevity and willingness to take risks
well i guess it's just a sort of
validation of what you know
you you feel deep down is that sort of
like you can
you've always got to bet on yourself and
you've always got to stick to your guns
in terms of artistic integrity
because the worst thing that can happen
is that you have a failure with
something that
you you weren't sure about yourself and
then even if you have a big success with
something that you weren't sure about it
will haunt you because you're thinking i
don't really like it
so they but i think what sparks have
done here's the answer is that what
sparks have done throughout their career
is that they've owned their successes
and failures and i don't think there's
any of the albums that you aren't you
know
in proud of in a way and that's a really
beautiful place to be
because at the end of the day like so
and especially now that's the nice thing
about this documentary is that people
have nice things to say about all the
albums and
i know like ronald russell was sort of
flawed by like flea
talking about introducing sparks one of
the albums that didn't really do
anything at the time but talking about
that one at length and knowing that one
off by heart
so i think that's the thing is that as
long as you can be
you know kind of like so be proud of
your successes and failures that's
that's a good place to be
we've we've seen last night in soho so
we don't need to give edgar any lessons
in daring
it's there all right well i'm excited
for that one as well
and thank you um this
thanks for answering my questions uh i
am going to move on to some audience
questions
um so this is from mitch
he says i'd love to learn about your
film journey that led to the upcoming
annette have you always written
screenplays as well
and is your approach to writing a
screenplay the same as approaching a new
album
no i mean we we actually
our passions within film now if they're
you know it is more in
doing uh movie musical projects because
we feel that
that sort of is where we have some
um unique kind of stance on
on how movie musicals can be done and as
a result of a net
which was going to be spark's next album
eight years ago
it's a narrative project but then
through a long circuitous path
it we met up with the french director
leos carrax he liked the
project and he he wanted to direct it as
a movie
so that kind of was how that project um
kind of the the the journey that that it
that it took
and so if there's something you know
that we have as a passion within
film now i think it's doing movie
musical projects we have another one
that we're working on
now that and and so
yeah rather than just uh screenplays for
dramatic films where we where there's a
lot better people doing
those than than us and even um doing
film just uh composing for films just
scores
we feel there's a lot of really talented
people doing
that really well but where we have a
kind of a unique
take on things would be with movie
musical so that's kind of what our
passion is now apart from sparks
i mean just in a technical way the first
many years there
there wasn't really a screenplay for for
annette it was kind of
having to do it after the fact because
there needed to be a screenplay written
but
for us it was just a treatment and then
and then
songs and musical expressions uh within
a narrative
framework and then at the end we were
told in a technical sense there had to
be
a screenplay so that was kind of tacked
on
did you have to learn final draft or did
you did you write it out
i just still don't have it no no i i
i let somebody who knows how to do that
do that
fair enough post-it notes yes that's
very
that's great for someone to have to
transcribe it um
so the film is two hours and 20 minutes
which by the way
flew by and like i said i watched it i
think two times just
consecutively so but someone chris asks
were there any scenes that you had to
cut
out due to time that you regret or wish
you could have kept in
i mean there's there's lots of uh stuff
i mean there's a certain point we just
have to make choices of like um
you know what you want to put in i mean
there was like a way interestingly there
was a shorter cut at one point
a little bit shorter and i showed it to
a director friend and he said i have one
note and it was a good one he said he
goes
i want to hear the songs a bit more and
i said you're so right
you're so right because i think there's
so many music documentaries that assume
prior knowledge by the viewer and
sometimes
even really good ones don't let people
in who don't know the artist
and with sparks it was obviously
incredibly important to make it
as much an introduction as a celebration
so i i did that and i probably added
about
you know five minutes to the length of
the movie just by let's just hear more
of this song
and more of this song and more of this
song but it was the right thing to do i
mean
there were things that we shot which
kind of once we'd established
the momentum of the film that they were
really sweet but they just didn't fit
where we did quite a lot of on location
stuff that would like really like sweet
little vignettes and they're all going
to be on the blu-ray we've just been
working on that at the moment where
the blu-ray i think for sparks fans and
fans of the movie is going to be quite
something because it has an
entire concert that i shot i shot the
live concert so there's like a 90 minute
concert
which is great and then there's these
other bits mostly these things like
raw interviews or longer stories that
you can't really stop for
somebody's five-minute story or like
little vignettes where we were on
location like there's some really sweet
things like with ronald russell going
back to the first place they played a
gig
but once we tried to put those into the
edit it always felt like a different
kind of movie it felt like you know like
a
an episode of arena or something in in a
completely nice way
um but it didn't fit what we'd sort of
established with the kind of the
the oral history sort of the momentum of
that
so those bits will be on the blu-ray
and i think they're all at work as nice
little short featurettes in their own
right
amazing all right so a different kind of
movie here but
sparks if they ever made a biopic about
you
are there any actors you have in mind
who could portray you
[Laughter]
you go first oh yeah well
i i first of all i don't i really don't
want to buy a pick mate i
i uh it everything becomes then overly
dramatic out of necessity and all but uh
i'll go with i'll go with benedict
cumberbatch oh damn he was playing me
he was right in a dual role
yeah like the winklevoss twins yeah yeah
i go for a boulder idea muppets
you do the voices but it's essentially
puppets that all right
uh green lit yeah yes
it just got great you want to see that
film now
absolutely i want to see both how about
two docupix one with benedict
cumberbatch in both roles
and then the muppets and the other one
the same
split screen no doing the same thing on
the opposite sides of the screen yes
good idea
all right edgar this is from marla how
did you decide who to include among the
talking heads
and how did you find them because some
seem a bit random like cotton oswald
and others seem perhaps hard to locate
like some of the fans
so how what was that process like well i
think um
i don't think patton is that random in
the sense of like not
unsurprisingly a lot of comedians are
fans of sparks
and like that that completely tracks and
in terms of like defining the people it
was like there were like three
elements to it there were people that
ronald russell had worked with
and uh you know grown up with um
then there were people who were already
like noted fans like thurston moore who
you
you
like from the your friend from the
barbecue like so the person is on record
as being a spark fan
so that jiren duran so in new order
vince clark
so those people we just wanted to track
down because we knew they loved the band
and then the third wild card was more
people that i assumed that they liked
sparks and four out of five times i was
right
and so in a weird way that's how i found
the random people because i would say to
people like your good friend fred
armisen
mike myers neil gavin patton oswald
scott ockerman
um you know say a beck flee
i'd say you you must be a sparks fan
right oh i love sparks
and that's how a lot of those came
together but i do think like
you know and what's interesting about
people as well i didn't think anybody's
um anybody's ex nobody's experience of
the band
was wrong as in there wasn't like a
minimum
requirement of knowledge one of the
things about sparks
and this actually this is interesting
about patton i asked him if he loves
sparks and he goes angst in my pants is
one of my favorite albums
but he didn't necessarily know a lot of
the other ones he is just like
laser focused on that one and then
when i asked him to be in the
documentary then he like really quickly
like
end up and he goes now i know everything
so but you know like just because
somebody just knows one album does that
mean that they're like
not equipped to talk about it no it's
like that that's what's great about
i mean we're all of the we're all we all
know what it was like
pre-internet where you could just be
obsessed by
one album because it was the only album
that was in the library
or it was the only album that was in the
record store like
people are like spoiled these days by
having an entire discography laid out on
the internet because
that wasn't the case that you would have
to kind of like just get obsessed by
different things so
in that sense i was well aware and why
sometimes some of the
people the commentators seemed kind of
not random but from different walks of
life i just thought it was a nice way to
show
the massive cultural footprint
that sparks have sure
all right this is from rick i loved the
early family stories and growing up in
los
angeles did your mother or family get to
see your success
or were they supportive of your artistic
journey
well our father unfortunately didn't get
to see it but our mother
our mother did she was a massive
sparks fan number one and uh you know
she was
she was always slightly reticent about
us
pursuing a career in you know evil rock
and roll
because uh she said oh you're
college-educated guys with degrees and
you get a real job
and then once she saw us on top of the
pops
uh she said there's my boys
uh i told you they'd amount to something
good so
she couldn't have been prouder and so
she was yeah huge fan
right how did you survive the six year
period from 88 to 94 when you didn't
release music
did you ever want to give up or go
through periods when you stopped making
music
well that period we were actually um you
know we were working all the time and
that was
you know we were we were working on the
my the psychic girl
project and it's discussed a bit in the
in the documentary and
and if there was one regret maybe was
that we
put all our eggs into the enjoy the tim
burton basket
uh as it were at the time and you know
and tim was
you know tim was really passionate about
the project my the psycho girl was a
another movie musical based on the
japanese manga
and so um unfortunately after a rewrite
that he requested
from the screenwriter um he went on to
some other project
has been kind of lingering in his uh you
know his
stack of uh project to do projects and
and in any case so you know we were
still active
you know incredibly active and it was
just that the public didn't see the uh
the fruits of any of that work that we
were doing and doing that
during that whole period we we learned
the one lesson i mean just
russell referred to it just that that
despite
any excitement that we have working on a
film
project or any other kind of non-album
project
it's really important for us to continue
working on the one thing that we can
control
which is a sparks album so that's always
got to be side by side i mean you know
to say it's a back up is kind of
diminishing what it is but just just
just to kind of have something
that you know that you can do and
you know that you can control
sure i mean it is an embarrassment of
riches but i mean
and we're so lucky as fans that right
now i mean
especially with with film it can be so
slow
or cumbersome and often never comes to
fruition the fact that we have this
documentary
we have a net we have edgar's upcoming
film
um in addition to this one like it's
wonderful for all three of you so
uh i'll end with because i think we're
at the end um
time wise what is next for sparks
music wise will you be on tour and then
i'll throw that to you as well edgar and
what's next
for you we're uh we're in the midst of a
new album
and um we'll be touring we had two tours
postponed because the pandemic
but we'll be touring north america 17
shows uh starting in february and uh
it'll be launched with a big show at the
disney hall in los angeles
uh i think it's february 8th so but
that's the start of a north american
tour and then we go to
europe and uh yeah and then annette
coming out
uh in the summer opening cannes film
festival so
we'll see where that all leads to so
cool
edgar last night in soho and then the
casual opening in the cannes film
festival
oh yeah i don't think oh opening the
canned film festival thing no big deal
so many film commitments
um i i i am promoting this movie
and we're going to carry on promoting it
in europe and then i have
my film last night and so coming out in
late october
and then i haven't i mean i have various
things in development and i've been
writing but
i don't honestly know what exactly the
next thing is and hopefully by the time
i finish doing the soho press it will
become clear to me what
the next one is so tbd
right well i i i do sort of hate that
question i apolo because i feel like
that we always want to seem like we're
working on 20 things like there's just
this pressure to
but really the reality is that you guys
are successful and inspirational because
you work really hard on a singular thing
and
and focus and put all your heart and
soul into it so
i want to thank each of you for
continually doing that kind of work and
for
inspiring us and for making a great film
and
sparks for being one of the greatest
bands of all time so
um thank you thank you so much gary
thanks carrie
thanks for everyone who tuned in today
and uh
i guess we're at the end and we will say
farewell thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
you